[Music]
you
friends welcome back to this section on
concepts and categories we will continue
this section from the earlier one by
revising some of the things that we did
in the earlier section on concepts and
categories so the things that we studied
in the section on concepts and
categories was we looked at what is a
concept and what is a category and how
does this concepts and categories really
work and so the basic definition that we
look there is concepts are kind of metal
buckets where you fill in things where
you fill in items instances or events
and categories are basically a process
of organizing knowledge into these means
which are called conscious we also
looked at concepts as nodes which has
explained in terms of the semantic idea
of semantic memory idea or the
hierarchical model of semantic memory so
basically then forming a concept allows
us to ease out and form an organization
scheme for world knowledge and
categorization is the process where we
taken a new instance and go ahead and
fill it in two buckets mental buckets
which have at the top level or which are
described through the concepts basically
the bucket is described through the
concept and categorization the process
of filling up this bucket now we also
looked at some of the models of
categorization in the last class and so
one of the
model was the classical approach to
concept formation where we looked at
something called the necessary and
sufficient condition and what that
concept said or what that model said is
that there is something called the
necessary and sufficient condition which
every instance of a concept or a
particular mental bucket should have to
be categorized as a concept and so there
were critics to it one of the famous
critic being that this necessary and
sufficient condition is not always
validated and the idea of cognitive
economy which says that the looking at
every instance or looking at every idea
of necessary and sufficient feature in
particular in all instance will not be
enough we also looked at the prototype
view and the exemplar view where in the
prototype view we looked at how a
prototype is formed and how this
prototype helps us in categorization and
we saw that the prototype view scores on
to the classical approach of
categorization on several aspects and
what is a prototype then so it's
basically an idealized version of the
concept and so the idea is that the
prototype may or may not be in actually
instance but it has mental averages or
mental summaries of all instances which
belong into that particular category or
under that concept
similarly we looked at also called the
exemplar approach where we looked at how
examples of a prototype are basically
used for categorization and we looked at
that there is something called the basic
level of categorization or basic level
of organization above which there is a
superordinate level and below with there
is the subordinate level and looking at
the taxonomy or looking at an example
here
the basic level here is the one out of
which the concept is form for example in
the first case and the musical
instrument is the superordinate node or
the higher node the basic level is the
guitar and within the guitar the
subordinate node is the classical guitar
or some other form of folk guitar or
classical guitar so basically then what
the exemplar view said or basically
suggest is that there is a basic level
of categorization and from this basic
level of categorization you have a
higher level categorization or a higher
level node and a lower level node so
this is basically a summary of what we
did into the last class now let's
continuing with what we looked at the
theories of concepts and categorization
let's look at the next theory of
categorization and so the next view
which explains what categorization is
done how categorization is done and how
concepts are formed is the schema table
view and what does this view says so
this view says that it shares features
from both the prototype view and in in
that the schema tank prototype store
information that is abstract across
instances and the exemplar view that the
Scimitar examples of store information
about the actual instance so what does I
mean by this what do I mean by this so
basically what it says is that this view
the Scimitar view is actually a mixed
view and so it borrows the good parts it
borrows features from both the prototype
view as well as the exemplar and so how
is this schematic view the idea of
schematic view similar to the prototype
view basically it is similar because in
both the schemata and the prototype the
information are abstracted across
instances so basically what happens is
Kamata says that the schematic view is
similar the prototype view because here
forming a concept or forming or
the way of categorization is done
through looking at an abstraction and
this abstraction is generated across
instances so looking at mental somebody
or mental averages and how does it
become close to the exemplar view so
basically what it does is that whenever
we are doing this exam categorization or
whenever we are looking at this mental
average this mental average has at the
end of it or has at the top node of it
the an example of the category so
basically all in all the Scimitar view
is a mixture of both the views or the
prototype in the exemplar view and so it
says that we in the schematic view which
it is suggested that the categorization
happens through abstractions or
prototypes which are made from or which
are generated from a number of instances
looking at a number of instances and
these are mental summaries and also this
average or abstraction that we are
looking at is an actual instance which
basically means that as a prototype view
says that the prototype may not be an
actual instance but the schematic view
says that the prototype that we are
forming the abstraction that we are
forming or the one definition the one
form across which we are categorizing
actually exists which means that it is
an actual example of it and this is how
it is close to the exact value so we
skim the idea of what is a schema kind
what is a script in a chapter and memory
and so then we saw the schematic is
basically a way of looking at or
organizing knowledge organizing word
knowledge and so schemas are basically
kind of organization scheme under which
world knowledge is fitted whereas script
is basically a routine for a particular
schema or of particular schemata so this
idea of categorization then uses the
idea that people make mental schemas or
people make this mental bin
or basically mental barebone structures
on bases on which this categorization is
done and how is this verbal structure
really made so it is made in terms of
abstractions it is made from
abstractions of various incidences of
the concept and these prototype that is
made or these bare bone structure which
is made has an actual existence onto it
and so this is how the schematic view
differs from both the views that have
been we have studied up till now now the
thing is that schema tates are
frameworks of knowledge that has roles
slots and variables onto it so basically
it has this key matter that the bare
bone that we are talking it not only has
spaces for categorization but it also
tells you how the categorization is done
or basically how what are the slots for
categorization what are the variables
which decide how the categorization is
done and the various rows that each
factor play in categorization so that's
what a schemata is all about and in the
schematic view the categorization is
done through something called a
hierarchy structure so as in a prototype
you see that there's some some factors
or some features have a higher role or a
higher similarity and the other feature
features don't have a similarity so
similarly based on how similar items are
a hierarchy of closeness to the actual
concept of closeness to the actual
prototype is done and this is how the
schematic view really works now there
are several problems with the schematic
view which is there in the first is that
it does not clearly specify the
boundaries among various kamata's so as
we saw the scheme matters are actually
barebone or they are actually structures
on which items are categorized into so
and these structures are developed or
the
bare bones are developed through an
idealized representation or through
looking at various instances of what of
a particular object or a particular type
of event which exists now if that is
true then how does two scimitar differ
or what is the difference between what
is the clear boundary between two
schemata is not actually very clear and
so this clear-cut boundaries is doesn't
exist or is not specified by the schema
tableau we always have fuzzy boundaries
for example what would happen is that if
an item is classified in one that a
particular schematic it could also be
classified under some other schemata and
so what will happen is the dog if it is
classified under the schema of an animal
is also it also gets categorized into
the pet animal or a man's best friend
and so there are no clear-cut boundaries
of how this categorization or what is
the distinction or what is the boundary
line between different schema tasks now
the other problem is the schematic view
is that in the present view it's not
sufficiently delineated to be empirical
testing so if we don't have clear-cut
boundaries if we don't have we're asking
matter view begins and very tends if we
don't know that then we cannot go ahead
and do empirical testing to this idea
because since we don't know where the
schema starts and where it ends and what
is the boundaries between two schemas
empirical testing observable testing
cannot be done and so that's another
problem with it since we don't know the
boundary so we cannot define the
boundary conditions if we cannot define
the boundary conditions then data cannot
be collected and so they cannot be
tested now also questions like what
informations leads to schemata and how
they are modified plus the process of
using appropriate schema toss are not
known so how was this schema form first
of all what leads to the formation of a
schema or what kind of information are
gathered before the formation of a
schema that is not very clear so what
kind of information
get amalgamated and makes the schema is
not clear and also if a schema is made
and an instance comes in or even comes
in which doesn't fit the schema how is
the present schema modified for example
let's lick the example of a dog now the
idea is that most dogs the lovable
creature and so supposedly we have a dog
and so we have a schema of a dog the
schema for dog a schematic for doggies
it has four legs it barks it's a pet
animal and so on and so forth now there
comes a dog which actually goes ahead
and bite someone and so this dog is not
no more lovable although it has the
characteristics of the particular schema
or a particular categorization so how do
we fit this dog into it or a
temperamental dog for that example let's
take a chihuahua which is a very very
temperamental dog now how do I fit a
Chihuahua into the idea of the dog ears
dog that is therefore Marian is the most
lovable dog or you have golden
retrievers which have very lovable dogs
so chihuahua is a very very
temperamental dog so how do I fit it and
so the schemata which is of a dog how
does it get modified what is the way in
which modifies so obviously that's not
present the plus the process of using
appropriate schemata is also not known
so when we are classifying the dog in a
wildlife and when we are classifying the
dog as a dog in a home what is the
process that we are using for
classificatory stew classifications that
also is not known and so the process of
using appropriate schemata of when a dog
becomes a wildlife animal and when they
become pet and when they become man's
best friend that is also not clearly
defined in a schematic view so how does
the schema changes from one context to
the other or one moment to the other
that is also not available and so that's
a big problem with the schema Tavia so
next on is the knowledge-based view and
so what does this view says the idea of
the knowledge-based view is that a
person classifying objects and events
just compare so what does this view say
this says that when people are comparing
people are making classifications or
categorizations they are not doing
physical comparisons but they are also
thinking about the way in which a
particular category is organized so it's
a two-part process they are not just
going ahead and looking at features and
ca-- when people are categorizing
they're not just looking at features of
an item physical features of an item and
then going ahead and comparing it what
they do is they are also mentally
thinking about the organization process
about how the organization process work
and what is the organization scheme and
that's what it says is that people just
don't compare features of physical as
personal object to the features of the
aspect of the stored representation and
said the people also use his or her
knowledge of how the concept is
organized to justify the classification
right and so what is the meaning of this
the meaning of this is that people are
not stupid so when they are doing some
kind of categorization they just don't
do the categorization as a machine would
do by just looking at certain aspects
and matching certain aspects so they are
not looking at it's close to how what a
template matching model is and
perception so people just don't look at
certain templates or people just don't
look at certain features and go ahead
and make the comparisons and based on
those comparisons classify different new
instances or of any element of any
concept into a particular category what
they do is they also think about why the
organization has to be done why is he
categorizing it and then why is he or
how is he
categorizing the whole or how is the
whole process of categorizing going on
and why does he do that to explain why
certain instances happen to go together
in the same category so this is
basically one of the thing so what
happens here is that people just don't
do physical comparisons they think about
the physical comparisons of
objects and they do the categorization
processes and that is why things which
don't belong together are categorized
for example let's say we have a five
item is given to you and a
categorization scheme is named now these
items are a child a dog
you're very valuables a laptop and some
money now how does these five things
classify together or they are
categorized together
no absolutely looking into it just from
the just from a third-person perspective
you wouldn't think that they have
anything in common what is a child has
common with a laptop and where some
valuables that you have and some money
that you have so none of them are
actually in any category or sort to
propose any form of category but then if
I give a name to it for example things
to be saved when in a fire then it makes
sense to you and so what people do is
they don't just look at these four
things and do the categorization they
also think how they are related to each
other and this thinking of the
organization scheme then leads them to
make the classifications and so this is
what event actually talking about so
people then think about the
organizational scheme and justify the
classification so in this case the four
items can be classified together how
they are classified together by looking
at the fact that these are the things
that needs to be saved when a fire is
there so more previous views of
conscious fail to answer so most
previous views of the concepts they fail
to answer satisfactorily how things in
the same category go together the
knowledge base you propose that people's
theories or mental experience about the
world are intertwined with their
concepts and provide the basis of
categorization so up till now the
theories that we have looked at they
don't look at instances or they don't
the beauty satisfaction and answer of
how people from different categories are
categorized together right or people
which are which have very low similarity
how they are classified together but
this theory the knowledge based theory
they say the people have their own
theories and men and mental explanations
about the world and these theories and
mental explanations help us in forming
concepts and helping us categorize and
some of the most weirdest of elements
together then can be given a theory for
categorization and can be categorized
together
so here this knowledge based view gives
us the scope to categorize the most non
natural or most asymmetrical objects
into a kind of a symmetry that's that's
the fine kind of a thing that this
particular idea of categorization helped
us now the five approach to conceptual
structure the five theory that we have
looked at they can be divided now
categorized into suit two subtypes
and this suppressor provide provided by
comes a two in 1992 so what are the two
categories so the five categories that
we have looked up up till now they can
then be or the five different models
that we have looked at till now they can
be clubbed into two basic categories
what is it the first category is the
similarity based category and the other
is the knowledge based category so in
the similarity based category we can
classify the classical approach the
prototype approach of the exemplar
report and parts of the schema view can
be these models can be put into the
similarity based category so what does
it say it includes approaches in which
categorization is assumed to be based on
similarity of an instance to an abstract
abstraction revivification of the
category and so why these four models or
why these three models and part of a
model is similar as I said the schematic
view
or it it possesses parts of the
prototype view and parts of the exemplar
view right and so basically how they are
together or how they are clubbed
together the idea how they are clubbed
together is that all these use our
similarity based system so they talk
about that concepts and categorization
or concepts are former categorization is
done based on how a new instance or how
close a new instance is or how similar
and unions instance is to the available
concept the more similar it is the more
easily it is categorized into that bin
otherwise it is taken to some other mean
or it is pushed out of that particular
bin so the more similarity you have to a
particular concept the higher the
chances of being categorized into that
particular concept the more close our
animal looks to a dog the higher the
chances that it should be categorized in
a dog category the more clothes animal
looks like a cat the higher the chances
that it will be classified as a cat
right and so similarity based view so
that's why and so the problem with this
view then would be that are typical
incidences will not be part of its for
example if I have a three-legged dog or
if I have a dog such as a Doberman now
the Doberman dog has a very very long
tail and so for its own survival
sometimes the tail is chopped off and so
if it doesn't have a tail right how do I
go ahead and classify so this view says
that I will not be able to classify the
Doberman into a dog category right why
because it doesn't have the absolute
similarity that we're looking at and so
this view is based on this idea of
abstracts there's specifications of a
category the idea that things which are
classified into a category should have
things or should have properties which
are similar
now the key critic of this view or the
similarity is meaningfulness only in
certain aspects so basically the
similarity waist view is meaningful in
certain respects only in certain other
respects there it is it doesn't generate
meaning so in for example in in
arithmetic or in in those Sciences this
mu will be very nicely looked at because
problems can be categorized into certain
formulas a certain mathematical problem
could be akin to certain other
mathematical problem it means lend a
solution to it and so we can look into
it for example integral most integral
indefinite and definite integral could
be classified into a certain way of
solution to it but then the for certain
other kind of solutions where a new
approach is needed some kind of mental
knowledge is needed or some kind of work
on the mental knowledge is needed or
some kind of work from the person who's
categorizing is needed some effort from
the person who's categorization is
needed there this this view will fall
now the other category is the
explanation based category and so what
is this category it comprises of the
schema table view and the
knowledge-based view so it as I said the
Scimitar view a part of it is the
prototype view part of it is the
exemplar view right and so the half part
which is the exemplar view then falls
under this category and so this mu has
comprised of part of the Scimitar view
and the knowledge based view and so what
does the meaning of this or what is the
proposal of this explanation based
category the idea is that people using
this view they base classification on
meaningful relationship among instances
and categories so people who use this
kind of explanation based view they do
not look for the explanation so they do
not look for similarities rather
categorization is done in terms of
meaning of how things are related
together in meaning and that is why the
previous example that I gave you in
which a dog a child some variable that
you have and certain amount of money
that you have are not clubbed together
because how they are clubbed together
because they are the things that you are
going to save and
that reason the man our dog and that
could also be classified together
because they form a household right and
so this is how they are classified
together but then looking at it in terms
of similarities a dog is not equal to a
man neither the man is equivalent to a
bed neither is equivalent to some other
household items or chair for example and
so the explanation will suggest that
with meaning or true meaning people can
do categorization and so categorization
or the property of categorization or
concept formations can also be done on
the basis of meaning now up till now
we've looked at the five models and a
combination model of how these
categories are generated or how this
category concepts are generated we will
now look at the fact of how a new
instance our new concept and
classification of new instances are done
what is the way in which people form new
concepts and new categorization and so
study was done by Bruner which we'll use
as a reference here so concept formation
requires some basic level of
generalization so when we are using a
when we're making a concept some kind of
features have to be generalized or with
all these instances all instances of a
particular category have to be looked at
and some commonality or some
generalization has to be looked at for
group grouping certain things but not
others together now the process requires
filling out what features are relevant
irrelevant with a little feedback so
basically in terms of concept formation
we should be focusing on generalizations
we should be focusing on commonalities
and we should also be looking at those
features which are relevant to us and
those which are which are not relevant
to us and only once we can do this
relevant
relevant kind of an identification can
we go ahead and then make concepts or
newer concepts so how do I make a
concept or how do i attain a concept and
for that purpose the process of
acquiring a concept in was acquiring the
information necessary to isolate and
learn a concept relating to the
formation of later use and
transformation of information to make it
usable when testing ideas and new
possible instances now to show how new
concepts are formed a study was done by
Bruner and others and so Bruner good now
in osteen in 1956 they did a study and
so what was the study like so it was a
very simple study in which they showed
people Bruner Austin and good now
they showed people a display like this
right and so this play had certain cards
onto it so certain cards were there and
the display had a card this kind of so
I'm just drawing a part of the display
so this kind of things our cards were
there and these card cards had certain
geometrical figures on unto it so either
it had a triangle it has a circle it has
a square or it had a rectangle so
basically then each card had one of
these features so either it had a
triangle
it had a circle or it had a square so
each card has either a triangle circle
or a square on to it in addition each
card also had black white and stripped
color onto it so each card was other
black white or strip kind of it so
basically the card was either black in
color or the figure was great in color
the figure inside was white or the
figure inside was striped that kind of a
thing was there so first feature it
had a number of three of these either a
triangle circle or square it had black
white or strip figures then it had
either 1 2 or 3 shapes into it so it
could have a single triangle it could
have two triangles or it could have
three triangles similarly it could have
one square one triangle it could have
one square one rectangle I'm sorry not a
rectangle one square one triangle one
circle and that kind of a thing in
addition it also had boundaries around
the shape so each card then had either 1
2 or 3 boundaries so 1 2 or 3 figures
and 1 2 or 3 boundaries so the variation
was that these were the four variations
these were the four aspects which varied
between the cards right so most people
were shown this kind of a system in
which each card has either 1 2 or 3
boundaries it had either 1 2 or 3
figures it had the four figures
classified as black white or striped and
it had either a triangle a triangle a
circle or a square onto it and so this
kind of figures were shown to people
later the experimenter gave a definition
concept the experimenter asked the
people a defining concept or it gave a
definition of a concept that things like
black circle in two borders strip figure
so he said that I am thinking of a black
circles a figure with a card with black
circles two borders and a strip figure
right so black circles two borders and
strip figure and the experiment has said
that in terms of classification so
subjects were asked to classify of how
many of these cards actually match the
concept that this experimenter gave me
so first people were shown this kind of
cards and later on they were given a
explanation like this of the concept of
the
is the concept the person the
experimenter is thinking of a concept
which has black circles in it has at
least doesn't say at least it says two
borders and then it says it is striped
in nature and so this kind of a thing
was given so these cards are either
black white or striped in nature and so
then after this the third step first so
this is step number one this is step
number two in step number three people
were shown up positive instance so two
borders two circles which are black one
another stripe so this is a positive
instance right and this was shown to
people and then people were asked to
look at this positive instance think
about this concept and later on go ahead
and verify how many of these or what are
the what all cards actually match this
kind of inclusion criteria inclusion
criteria for categorization now people
each time the subjects went ahead and
tested these cards each of these cards
for inclusion criteria a feedback was
given to them whether it was true or not
and so this is what the experiment was
so very simple experiment a number of
cards were shown to people these cards
varied on four variables one it had a
triangle each card has either a triangle
circle or square on to it then it that
the cards were either black white or
striped
third it had one two or three figures
onto it and it had one two or three
borders on to it later on a concept was
given by the experimenter saying that I
am thinking of a card with black circles
two borders and striped figure so that's
what I'm thinking about and then a
positive instance card was shown two
subjects and later on subjects were
asked to go ahead and match this
instance or basically tell the
experimenter which of these cards follow
or which of this card matched this
particular
concept that has been given and so when
the experiment was done Bruner and
others found that there are three ways
in which people went ahead and attained
the concept or did this particular kind
of a matching task people either use
cement image scanning successive
scanning or convert on conservative
focusing now in simultaneous scanning
what people did was all hypothesises
were tested the same time so people went
ahead and tested the black circles of
people compared number of black circles
to number of borders and number of
stripe figures at the same time right
so they verified all the hypotheses all
the points which have been given in one
single instant instance and that is
called simultaneous scanning so
simultaneously they verified all the
hypotheses or they verified if the
target card matched or the target card
had all these features or not in
successive scanning what people did was
they first matched whether the target
card whether the card which we were
matching to the concept had a bad circle
a black circle or not if it didn't have
a black circle it was left behind and
the next card was moved on to so that's
how people looked at so one hypothesis
the time so first they verified whether
people whether the cards had black
circles then they went ahead and
verified whether the cards that they got
from the first verification with black
circles whether they had two boundaries
or not and once that was done from that
group they looked at whether black
circle cards with two boundaries were
striped or not and that is how they did
and this is called successive scanning
in Kundel conservative focusing what
people did was they selected the
positive instance they looked at the
positive instance and then they started
comparing this positive instance to each
card so what they did was they compared
so they were not testing hypotheses they
were not eliminating hypotheses they
were looking at the positive instance
and comparing the positive instance with
each instance of the card and so what
Bruner
Goodenow and Osteen came up with is that
this is how people our team called
concepts and these are the strategies of
attaining concepts
they said that there are three ways of
attaining a concept one is called the
simultaneous scanning in which you go
ahead and compare all hypotheses the
same time then there is the successive
scanning in which one after another the
multiple hypotheses are compared one by
one and then there is conservative
focusing in which what you do is the
standard instance is compared and this
comparison is what basically leads to
the idea or leads to the matching and in
this comparison what we do is one
feature at a time is compared to the
target the target cards not with this so
this is what I was talking about and so
as you see there were stripe figures
there was darker figures I mean black
black figures they were white figures
number of boundaries number of signs
into it and so these were the cards
which were use and so any instance was
used and so these instants were how it
was tested so Brewin others 1956 found
that the effectiveness of each of these
strategies dependent somewhat on the
extent of the task conditions so the
question is which of the strategy is
better which strategy should be used in
which the strategy should be used when
and they found out when the strategies
we're not complex the simple strategies
for example arithmetic problems were
very simple or very straightforward
strategies people should be using the
simultaneous scanning but as strategies
become more and more complex as more and
more complex items have to be clubbed
together or categorized together people
should be using conservative focusing so
it's basically the task that has been
given to you the idealized conditions
that has been given to you how difficult
it is the more difficult the more
complex it is the
more conservative focusing we use the
more simpler it is the more successive
scanning that we use or simultaneous
scanning that we use so another question
was how do we acquire the prototype in
our concept formation so basically the
the card that was positive instances
that was given is actually a prototype
so how do I get a prototype so people
use and form prototype you haven't given
distorted instances during learning so
going back to the chapter on perception
where we looked at a study by Cillian
Posner where they gave people various
random patterns of the letter M and so
what happened is there were there were
low distortions and high distortions
pattern of or low distortions and high
distortions versions of the letter M so
remember if you if you remember from
that chapter so this is how a M would
look like and so this was the prototype
which was never shown to people what
people were shown where distortions of
it so for example this is one distortion
which people were shown and the other
distortion could be this
so several distortions were shown to
people and these distortions were high
distort so these were load instructions
because if you join together it will
form a M or in this case it from the M
like this and the high distortions
versions were also shown to people so
people if given both high distortions
and low distortions people and it was
found out that people work better or
people make prototypes better in in
terms of moderate distortion see if you
people are shown no distortions and they
are asked to make a prototype or people
are shown high distortions in both these
cases the prototype that they form are
not very convenient but if noticed
medico distortions and moderate
distortion the items are shown to them
or moderate distortion instances of the
actual prototype is shown to them they
can accommodate a large variation so
even if a large variation if the test
stimuli has a large variation into it
people who have been shown distortion
moderate distortion cards or modern
distortion versions of the original
prototype they are able to still
classify the test cut into their
prototype now learning about category
variability may be at least as important
as learning about prototypes especially
if categorizations are to be made later
and in instances that vary a great deal
from the prototype so category
variability is another thing how much
there is a variation in the category now
more variation in the category the more
distorted or the more bigger the
prototype would be or the time mentions
the prototype would have the bigger the
prototype abstractions would be and the
higher the lower the category
variability the more stronger the
prototype is or them the more contended
the prototype is so with category
variabilities this prototype also varies
now books 1978 they define something
called non analytical concept formation
in contrast to logical scientific focus
caution and they call this as implicit
learning and they require people to pay
attention to individual exam plus
storing information about
representations of them into memory so
what Brooks and others they
found out that people just as we saw in
prototype acquiring of how people
acquire prototype what people do is
people use implicit knowledge or people
use non analytical knowledge to form
concepts now even from the high
distortions of dots of an M or hardest
low distortion versions of M people were
still able to make the prototype and M
it basically means that people are able
to use implicit knowledge for forming a
prototype and how does it there because
people pay attention to individual
examples so people take all these
distortions and look at these
distortions and they pay attention to it
and from that they store information
about the representation of that
particular thing of that particular
abstraction in memory now later
classifications are done by comparing
new instances to the representations
drawing analogies between the old and
the new so what if a number of
variations of the dot pattern is
presented to people
we're from somewhere high distortions or
some or low distortions people will look
at all of them and then store the mental
prototype and then later on if still
variations of native variations when
they come in the the people compare
these variations with whatever has been
stored into memory or comparing to the
prototype which has been stored into
memory so in Brooks example what Brook
did was we Brooks presented people with
examples like this and so these were
words that represented to people and
people were asked to remember these
words no there was one rule which was
there and that what what the rule was
that some of these words followed a
certain kind of a grammar right and so
these words which which are here these
I'm sorry these are not words these are
letter string so these letter strings
are presented to people and people are
asked to remember these letter strings
or to predict how these letter strings
are actually formed now unknown to
people were the fact the some of these
letter strings followed are certain
rule a certain way of doing it our
certain language grammar for example
some of these words which are presented
here follow a grammar and so as you can
see this is the grammar this is the
structure of the grammar so a certain
rule has been followed in some of these
letter strings and in some of these
letter strings that tool has there not
been followed for example one rule is to
start here and then you can have a T to
start with or you can have a V to start
with so we have a T or or a V to start
with and then you can either have P a
number of peas into it and so this is
one in which we are having a number of
piece or you can have a number of X's
onto it and so this is the one which has
a number of X's to start with a V and
number of X's and then you can proceed
to either a T so this is a T or you can
proceed to either a V so this is this is
either a V and from there this T then
follows an S and so this is one the one
which follows this logic right or it it
it can from T it goes to an S and s then
comes back to X or it proceeds to the
end so basically what the experiment was
all about is that in this case these
letters some of these letter strings
followed a grammar and some of these
letter strings were a random pattern
which were there and so people were not
told some of these people were not told
that they followed a grammar strict kind
of a grammar and some of the people were
told that the letter strings that you
are using followed a kind of a grammar
onto it right and so later on they were
asked to so some people some of the
people were told that certain rule is
there from which this letter strings are
generated and some people were told that
there are no rules to it and so later on
participants when who learned better
strings that followed grammar rule made
few errors
then control participants now the thing
is that participants who were told that
they follow a grammar rule they perform
or made more errors in terms of
retrieval and then participants who
didn't follow this grammar rule
so if told about the rule people were
told that there was you know a rule
which was followed people who would
retrieve back or learn these strings
they made more number of errors and
people who were asked to just learn the
rule so three instances in one instance
people were not told anything and they
were asked to learn these words in
instance two people were told that see
there is a grammar rule and this grammar
rule isn't followed for making these
words and so each new instance then
follows this rule right and the third
group was there where they were shown
this rule right and they were not asked
to learn anything they were not stared
at anything about that whether it
follows a grammar rule or not they were
shown this prototype they were shown
this thing and they were asked to
classify what happened is what was the
result the people we were just own an
exemplar people who were just shown this
particular instance and they were asked
to classify based on this instance or
basically remember this instance based
on prototype they perform the best but
when people were said that a grammar
ruin is there and you have to deduct the
rule and fall based on that do the
categorization they performed poorly and
of course the people who were not said
anything about the rule or if any rule
exists implicit rule exists for learning
these words things they perform the
worst so that'sthat's how the result of
this example turns out to be also in
another example in another study people
were shown this kind of a hereo graphics
and a particular word related to this
hereo graphics and so what was the thing
here people were first shown that this
is the stress stimuli and this is the
response so this means wrong
this means gone
this means tiger this means bus and
later on they were asked questions by
showing this kind of a stimuli whether
this flies whether this is bigger or not
whether this is live or not and whether
this is attacks or not this kind of
questions were given now unknown to the
people where the fact that each of these
hey leo graphics that you see actually
mean something actually mean a
particular thing in English a particular
word in English right and so when P when
people were not shown people were not
told that this kind of meaning exists
they performed better they they made
this idea better and they could they
could just go ahead and relate this I
this implicitly this particular
Geographics to a particular concept but
when people were actually told that a
certain holographics mean actually
something the number of errors rainbow
so people who have just shown this and
later on tested on to this area graphics
they perform better why because they
implicitly made some kind of connection
they implicitly made some kind of a
connection of what this thing means what
this thing means and so on and so forth
but if they were just told that there is
some kind of a rule which is there and
they perform much over sir
Brooks then described five factors that
encourage people to store information
about individual exemplars and what are
these five things so Luke says that
first of all people are better off in
making concepts and categorization in
terms of exemplars and he's always
stated there there are five factors
which encourage people to make more
examples and what are these the first
factor involves learn information that
distinguishes among in in among
individual instances so if the task
requirement is such that it makes people
to learn more information that
distinguishes among
in individual instances if the
variability is more and people learn
more about individual instances they are
better off making learning through our
concept formation through through the
process of exemplar or using exam
process method for categorization also a
second factor factor is the original
learning situation so more closer the
original learning situation is the more
varied the original learning situation
is the higher the chances that people
will use exemplars for making
categorization also some stimuli lend
themselves to hypothesis testing better
than others and so what happens is there
are different different kind of similar
stimuli for example some dogs would be
called a dog that would be much better
example of a dog then some other kind of
dogs which are not better examples of a
dog and so what what would happen here
is that since some stimuli led to better
hypothesizing and some not a good
example a good way of categorization
would be using the exemplar similarly a
food factor that in real life is that in
real life concept learning instances may
belong to a number of categories so what
will happen is a particular instance in
the instance can belong to a number of
categories for example the dog could
belong to the the animal category to
man's best friend category to the
household category and so on and so
forth and so if that happens if the dog
is sharing so many categories there's so
much overlap an example is the best way
or example should be the best way of
categorization and the fifth thing is
that in natural setting we learn about
instances without knowing how we will be
called to use for information later and
so in most natural instances the
immediately we don't come to test a
particular instant or make a concept or
categorize something using a concept so
we learn a particular we see a
particular instance of something and
then we make a concept out of it but
immediately we are not given the task of
categorizing something according to that
concept it may happen that
or some period of time may exist or some
period I may laugh before we get at
instance of that category and so in
those cases example as a best example or
examples are the best way to go ahead
and categorize so this is the end of
this section and in this particular
section we saw how concepts and
categorization really work and what are
the various theories which help in
categorization and concepts and and then
also look compared across the different
categories we also saw how concept
attainment is done and what is implicit
concept the idea is that people use
implicit knowledge for cancer concept
formation and so that's another
interesting thing that we looked at and
at the end we also looked at the
examples are the best way of forming a
concept so in the next lecture when we
meet we'll talk more about a different
kind of memory or since they are still
continuing with a memory example in the
next section we'll talk about a
different kind of memory thank you
[Music]
you